[Música]
la asamblea general de naciones unidas
fijó cada 3 de mayo de 1993 como el día
mundial de la libertad de prensa se
eligió esta fecha para que coincidiera
con la declaración de huéneja que en
1991 otra iniciativa de la unesco en la
que representantes de medios africanos
habían llamado a defender una prensa
independiente
también pluralista y libre y proteger a
los periodistas en el ejercicio de su
profesión para ello señalaron que debía
evitarse los monopolios mediáticos como
estábamos hablando con rosa pérez
fomentar la financiación a medios
públicos favorecer la creación de
asociaciones y sindicatos de periodistas
además alentar a una cooperación
periodística global pedían la liberación
de periodistas en ese entonces
encarcelados por los gobiernos africanos
la censura es el gran desafío de la
libertad de prensa y el tema de
conmemoración de este año es el
periodismo bajo el asedio digital y para
ello conversamos con william cullen a
jefe del área de libertad de expresión y
seguridad periodistas de la unesco
gracia aguilera por estar nuevamente con
nosotros en directo américa de france
para nosotros es realmente un gusto cuál
es la situación de la libertad de prensa
en un mundo totalmente
digitalizado como además es el tema de
este año
muy buenos días a usted ya todos los que
le siguen en este programa un gusto
estar nuevamente acá para celebrar el
día mundial de libertad de prensa muy
feliz día
y como periodista y a todo tu equipo
porque este es el día de todos que hacen
la prensa
es cierto que
cuando hablamos de una celebración
pensamos que realmente hay cosas que
festejar pero en este momento lo que
tenemos que hacer es poner nuestros ojos
es subrayar los enormes desafíos y las
amenazas que la libertad de prensa sufre
en todo el mundo todos los reportajes
anteriores a esta entrevista ya han
subrayado algunas cuestiones
fundamentales déjame solo entrar
directamente entonces a por qué te
decidió elegir como temática central de
este año la idea de que el periodismo
está bajo asedio digital hace diez años
el sistema de naciones unidas ha
aprobado un plan que se llama el plan de
seguridad de periodistas y el tema de la
impunidad en 2002 estamos marcando los
10 años de la aprobación de este
importante mecanismo de protección de
periodistas cuando este plan fue
aprobado hace 10 años no estaban claros
los desafíos digitales que la seguridad
de los las periodistas iba a enfrentar y
ahora eso ya empieza a tener no no
tenemos toda la información pero pena
empieza a tener un encuadre más claro
uno de ellos son los mecanismos de
vigilancia que fueron mencionados en el
reportaje anterior pegasos es uno de
ellos pero desafortunadamente además
entonces periodistas y sus fuentes
desafortunadamente están siendo
vigilados y esto es muy malo para la
libertad de expresión la libertad de
prensa y luego para las para las
democracias pero no es sólo eso los
datos de la unesco demuestra un
creciente volumen de asedio y de acoso
digital contra los periodistas y
particularmente contra las periodistas
mujeres una de nuestras investigaciones
ha demostrado que se 173 por ciento de
las periodistas entrevistadas habían
sufrido algún tipo de acoso digital por
el trabajo que realizan y hay cosas más
sofisticadas nombres como docs y qué es
eso de que los perpetradores de la
violencia empiezan a divulgar dónde
viven los hijos de los periodistas donde
estudian porque eso es una presión
psicológica buscando evidentemente un
proceso de autocensura y por ahí baja
7 entonces en una palabra tenemos una
serie de desafíos para la seguridad del
periodistas de los de los de las
periodistas para el ejercicio de la
libertad de expresión en el mundo
digital a eso se suman cosas como
campañas de desinformación el tema del
discurso del odio en línea entonces pero
tenemos realmente un enorme desafío por
adelante y este día invitamos a todos
gobiernos jueces sociedad civil
organizada a ustedes periodistas medios
pero también la población en general es
decir como juntos podemos enfrentar un
problema de tales dimensión
claro y precisamente con tantos desafíos
o cómo se puede hacer para que estos
desafíos vayan disminuyendo porque
pareciera ser que a medida que pasan los
años los desafíos son aún mayores sin
superar los que hemos tenido
anteriormente digamos como el tema de la
violencia como el tema de los asesinatos
a los periodistas sobre todo en nuestra
región digamos méxico-colombia en
venezuela que es una prensa totalmente
también es censurada
agua cómo hacer para para ir superando
estos desafíos y que no se sumen y se
sumen y se sumen y al final pareciera
que nunca vamos a superarlos
sí es cierto tenemos acá primero tenemos
como tú decías viejos y nuevos desafíos
desafortunadamente no llegamos a los
nuevos sin que cuestionar totalmente a
los viejos pero también es importante
hacer una mirada en sobre las conquistas
que hemos alcanzado en estos últimos 30
años entonces la cuestión que tenemos en
nuestras manos en este momento es
precisamente cómo hacemos más robustas
estas conquistas o sea cómo hacemos que
los lo que se ha ganado en términos de
libertad de expresión de libertad de
prensa en los últimos 30 años desde que
la declaración original de bildu fue
aprobada no se pierda y es cierto que
hubo muchos avances o sea la
prensa libre independiente y plural es
más libre más independiente más plural
de lo que era hace 30 años te doy un
ejemplo hace 30 años teníamos solo 12
países en el mundo con leyes de acceso a
la información pública hoy son 132
eso es suficiente tener leyes no hay que
implementarlas pero es un primer paso
entonces cómo hacemos para intensificar
estos estas conquistas que ya fueron que
ya alcanzamos pero al mismo tiempo sin
perder de perspectiva cuáles son los
retos incluyendo los viejos retos el
plan de seguridad naciones unidas- hace
una sugerencia muy concreta a los
estados tenemos que desarrollar lo que
llamamos las políticas de los tres pes
prevención protección y procuración de
justicia
eso sin importante aunque hacer
prevención protección y procuración de
justicia en relación a los crímenes
digitales es muy distinto entonces algo
los mecanismos de seguridad de
periodistas que fueron implementados en
muchos países con buenos resultados hay
una reducción del número de asesinatos
en países donde estos mecanismos fueron
implementados de manera correcta
necesitan ahora ajustar la lógica de
estos mecanismos para enfrentar los
desafíos en el mundo digital incluyendo
una perspectiva de género muy clara
porque las mujeres primero periodistas
sufren más los ataques digital
hitler y rápidamente ya para finalizar
nuestra nuestra conversación los
desafíos para informar como digamos
cuáles cuáles son los que tenemos por
delante y sobre todo en nuestra región
latinoamericana y además cómo hacer para
informar en estos tiempos de guerra como
lo estamos viendo en esta guerra en
ucrania
y eso quizás sea una de las buenas
noticias del mundo digital o sea desde
una perspectiva de la libertad de
expresión la libertad de prensa la
internet es la más grande revolución
desde que wüttemberg inventó la prensa y
ahí hay buenas noticias en el sentido
por ejemplo que la información
periodística y la colaboración y
cooperación entre periodistas de
distintos países es una una cuestión
fundamental para enfrentar los problemas
que son problemas globales o por ejemplo
panamá papers es uno de estos ejemplos
entonces yo creo que la cuestión es cómo
aprovechamos las enormes oportunidades
el mundo digital ofrece al periodismo ya
la libertad de prensa al mismo tiempo
mitigando los riesgos que tenemos este
es el desafío